thanks to hamilton for sponsoring a
portion of this video stick around to
find out how you can get your hands on
the official watch of far cry 6. welcome
back i'm glad you could join me today
the point of a bob ross challenge is
usually to create the most relaxing
beautiful landscape you can't however
we've taken that and turned it into a
anxiety inducing competition
now he's adding yellow
and just beat the devil out of it
we're back with one of our favorite
challenges the bob ross challenge we
will be watching a bob ross episode
today and in real time following along
in a 3d application of our choice to
make a cgi version of one of his works
of art the catch is we have to do it at
the exact same speed as he is there's no
way we can keep up with bob ross we are
literally trying to model trees at the
same time he's painting them because he
just goes
so we are going to be gathering our
assets beforehand so when it comes time
to follow along with the episode we're
good to go you don't even know what i'm
capable of i have petabytes of assets
ready to deploy at a moment's notice i
got six i'm not really an asset guy
myself i'm more of a sculpting guy my
middle name is asset lord niko i put
more time dedication to getting the
highest quality premium assets more so
than anybody else here my pictures win
purely because of all my assets that i
use did you win the first challenge no
sam knocked out all the pockets is
unreal forced to know what assets we
need to gather we need to look at the
picture it's gonna be a time limit at
least give us like 10 seconds
no two seconds we only get five no
two seconds
[Music]
no i caught a glimpse of it on someone's
phone earlier
you you just you you want the other
records
there's no in the other room you usually
cut this part out of the video so yeah
five seconds
three
two don't use a black one
i feel pretty confident about this one
all right we're back up three two
oh yeah ocean water is the easiest thing
to do god knows how you're going to do
the water well i'm really even helping
this there's an asset for everything
[Laughter]
i gotta get to work
i have an idea
that is so radical i'm worried about
being disqualified
coming okay
i have an ipad
as worried as ren is i'm twice as
worried okay and i gotta center myself
and really channel the bob ross at me
push through it's interesting though
because he's so at peace to make a piece
like that so violent and angry
what is he hiding
making giant curling waves is really
hard i might have to do it by hand or i
could use unreal's sweet water system
that they have released this year i'm
going to take it beyond the painting
yeah yeah we see a beach but what
happens if you turn the camera the other
direction what's what's hiding what's
hiding out back there while i might lack
in in curling curvy splashing waves i'll
make up for with my robust gameplay
today outside of sam and i our
contestants are ren and jordan i do not
have a trick up my sleeve i believe in
the process i believe in bob ross i have
my lucky charm here with me
i'm feeling good
i'm i'm honestly a little bit nervous
because i legitimately have never done
an art tutorial before and that's pretty
much what this is so i don't know what
we're gonna get now we got a little
twist here all of us have a little bell
everybody can ding their bell once and
if you ding your bell the video pauses
for five minutes but your bell gets
taken away so all of us have a little
moment if our program crashes if we get
a little bit behind we can pause the
video only once 28 minute bob ross
tutorial begins
now
welcome back certainly glad to see you
today you ready to do a fantastic little
painting with me all right bobby show us
what you got the top of it i've covered
with a thin even coat of liquid white
and we have a piece of masking tape wait
i need i need tape can you grab me oh
brown
that works man go right into a small
small amount of the indian yellow yellow
what time of day does that mean 5 p.m
and we'll just do something
about like that oh that's the sound i
like to hear oh boy oh boy just screw
this tape this is so stupid we live in
the digital era i don't need analog
tools like tape running bears are drawn
better start drawing loading in my
assets i know there's going to be an
ocean at some point so i'm just going to
no
later
shake it
and just beat the devil out of it
all right good we're ready i suck at my
mousepad there we go uh how about more
contrast in that sky how about some like
yeah oh my god he's getting purple in
there ooh super saturated
see what's nice is i can actually undo
here oh are we not doing the whole undo
thing
i know he's going to waves i'm getting
my waves in
i can't wait on this sunset any longer
all these waves look so bad
oh gosh
okay i'm actually i need to uh go back
and add more of that purple
[Music]
just lay in some places i am not really
there yet
jesus christ oh there we go it's working
the governor's banner is definitely
there's gonna be like he's gonna be like
a torn man the man who's
been you know he's come to this island
left his home in england and even though
he's gained so much gold and wealth and
riches you know there's still something
lacking in his life so i'm thinking i'll
make him a really complex character if
you look at how easy this is i'm just
like taking my shoreline and i'm like
how about this over here look at that oh
my god he's already straight up into all
the white stuff what brush should i use
for that maybe drawing
i am so in over my depth right now man
he's got this band of color here and i
can actually bring that in by using some
uh some mediums here instead of 4d i'm
seeing some progress bob's moving really
fast so
yeah bob's got the sky done already this
guy's almost done already so these guys
would have to pick up the speed or use
some bells oh my god
i really need to
i'm going to undo all of it i'm going to
ding it i'm going to ding it no no no
i'm just going back so let's say our
major wave
it's going to live whoa what are you
doing bob
what's that
i think the governor's daughter is
definitely going to go with the rogue
pirate mccaffrey because you know
while he doesn't have the same esteem
and noble status that her parents want
her to have he definitely you know he
cares for her genuinely and i think
together they'd make a formidable force
in the caribbean
that's a purple ocean okay the challenge
is that like we're all doing photo reel
based rendering and like bob here is
just like i'll put whatever color i want
thank you oh there's more wave than i
thought
i'm like actively trying to hide my wave
assets
they're really bad which one was i using
acrylic is he is he painting with
acrylics
[Music]
okay that's not what i wanted was it did
he put down the base layer of purple was
that what he did what are we doing here
oh oh big waves we got big big waves oh
i got to get my big waves going i
totally forgot holy crap
oh okay pausing it didn't really help me
too okay there we go
there you go yeah one bell down i wonder
if i can float
floating pawn movement now how do we get
stuff to float in the water no we'll
figure that out later i probably should
get my tree in okay get it
i'm trying to learn how to like do
actual like layer based stuff here so
he's adding a bunch of darkness
kind of up here at the horizon
we're at low tide right now and the
docks at the port city of saint germain
they're getting dry thank you for these
five minutes run
we're back on track i need fall off
that's what i need okay i'm gonna go to
my brush paper stroke path fall off
there we go
looking for a secret check the
marketplace
i've left the secret note for you under
the box of apples
there we go potato no no what are these
potatoes what are these fruits i can't
whatever all right
there it is
it's not quite exactly this gap but
it'll work
okay so look i know that this is the
section of the video a lot of you guys
are like oh jake's on screen here comes
a brand integration and yeah usually
it's true okay and i'm sorry to do this
because i'm not sorry i'm not always
gonna be here okay i'm not always gonna
be here to give you guys sweet discount
codes and urls that you can go to to get
exclusive offers like right now today
courtesy of today's sponsor hamilton
that's right this portion of the video
is sponsored by hamilton and i have a
very exclusive offer on how to get an
in-game far cry 6 watch that nobody else
is going to be able to get that comes
from one of the best watchmakers in all
of hollywood in all of storytelling and
in the world a favorite of filmmakers
for decades has been hamilton watches
that's right they've appeared in over
500 hollywood films and of course in
many blockbusters that you've obviously
heard of including tenant interstellar
jack ryan and the men in black franchise
these guys have been around for quite a
while making some of the most incredible
classy and durable equipment that you
could put on your wrist and they're
going further than just hollywood with
far cry 6. that's right the famous
ubisoft franchise far cry now in its
sixth iteration is about to take place
on the fictional island of yara which is
a caribbean island ruled by the cruel
dictator anton castillo played by the
real life famous actor giancarlo
esposito who you may know from the hit
show breaking bad on october 7th in the
far cry 6 game players will have the
opportunity to wear this virtual
timepiece in game and
1983 special edition watches only 1983
will be available in real life at
hamiltonwatch.com that's right this is
the official hamilton khaki field
titanium far cry 6 limited edition watch
the official watch of far cry 6. so if
you guys are interested in getting your
hands on this exclusive limited edition
watch or finding out more about this
offer head on over to hamiltonwatch.com
farcry6 or just click the link in the
description below that's
hamiltonwatch.com
6. thanks again to them for sponsoring
this portion of the video and now yeah i
guess now we can go back to the bob ross
vfx challenge okay come on let's i'll go
with you come on i'll go with you i'll
see you out there all right
we have the entire canvas blocked in now
now we can begin getting serious about
it now you're getting serious about it
what have i done what have i done my
gizmo my gizmo my gizmo how do i know
which way is up
oh my goodness dude
oh he's a wizard oh my god he's already
on the axis
um for 20 bucks i'll let you hit mine
you know what i'm
gonna ignore you right now
actually i might need that so i'll take
that back oh he's got all these layers
in the distance
it's gonna be a little bit smaller there
we go oh that's looking pretty
i'm trying to like this dude am i gonna
have to use the xyz coordinates for
freaking all this now well
i'm doing it because i can't get my
transform gizmo back another bell to the
graveyard post processing light type no
developer visualize
advanced oh my god
um i broke my program i shouldn't have
tried to make a whole economy
nick i don't need this how dare you
shame me for all my ambitions
oh they're back okay
the cult of saint germain lives again
that's not nearly bright enough maybe i
need a different pen for this maybe i
will go with the wet acrylic does anyone
else have wet hands yeah my hands are so
wet
that's the biggest battle
short computer
oh god unreal just crashed
waves on waves it's easy for me to make
waves it's trivially easy i can have as
many waves as i want no one cares i
actually know i'm really excited to see
your wave plug-in it looks like it's
really doing the job for you
uh all right let's do the important
stuff characters all right here we go
all right well we're testing this out
right now the purpose of this test is to
feel out whether the like the actual
layout of saint germain is kind of
working with pedestrian traffic
okay i'm gonna put some
froth on my waves that's where you put
your bright spots
barely touching maybe right here
oh there we go that was the key i had to
make the tiniest brush
yellow
all right here we go port city of saint
germain i think is generally complete
here we go i found a red brush
oh that was
this is obviously the mayor's home
oh yes lord hamilton lowell hamilton
some say
he's the great pirate deathbeard who's
changed into a disguise all right here
we go done
oh anyways uh so
sunset and waves is the theme okay let
me work on that part a little bit here i
guess closer up we'd want bigger
bigger white caps closer up and smaller
white caps in the distance
i'm putting a little a little extra
something in there a little nod of love
to bop himself
all we're doing is just scrubbing it in
put the shadow in put the shadow in
[Music]
jordan you really need some help man you
you've got to like maybe
think about how you want to proceed from
here i'm not going to use my paws no
you're not going to use your paws
it's silly what about for the common
good you know why don't you use it for
everyone else maybe said be selfish wait
i forget i have a freaking ocean brush
organic water
um i think i have an ocean brush
spires
i'm definitely not gonna get that froth
in here but it's okay this is crap
floating in the sky
i should figure out what's going on
there
there we go
oh thanks jordan oh that was really kind
of you problem yeah when you got a ding
you got a ding you got it
i dig for rent okay third person digging
there we go so digging
oh i could give him a bottle of rum
here we go bottle green there we go
i guess i could work on some foliage
let's go right up here decide where your
palm tree lives maybe
this palm tree maybe lives right here
skinny boy oh that's a skinny boy let's
give him a friend we want him to get
lonely who's skinny boys we got a dual
skinny boy oh shoot let me go back and
make him modification control w
done
well yes no i was prepared for a double
skinny boy it honestly looks a lot
similar to how i remembered it from the
five seconds but there's like way less
wave action than i expected so i may
have found overboard but you do it you
can sir i'm gonna wrap this up in three
minutes
seriously oh my god
octane winner get some weird stuff
okay you know what
screw it i'm moving on to the tree
artistic
you still using
the acrylic
that's one of the nicest ways
to make a little palm tree i hope you've
enjoyed this little tropical sunset type
scene
yes
yes
my hero fourth pause and then when we
get back you have
the credits to do your final touches the
credits time is the worst part of this
video so like the credits are all cool
and chill and happy and everyone's like
literally freaking out i feel myself
drawing near and near to the screen as
we get closer i'm in detail mode now
sam's bouncing as knee you must be
nervous i'm just trying to see if i can
get my waves going further out into the
water you know like i got great waves
that are up close but i need some like
distant waves you know what i'm saying
okay now check this out i can take this
layer
i can duplicate it
and select it
it's coming together
my wave looks like [ __ ]
oh yeah
really locking it in
it's like a hard line in front of it no
time to do any displacement on this
frickin water
and i look forward to painting with you
again until then happy painting and god
bless
oh this is the sound the music is
helping can i record this for the
soundtrack really quick i have no more
moisture in my body
goodness
epidemic
sound let's see if i can get music in
here fast
oh gosh all right i'm just gonna let it
render
it's over it's over hands off fingers
oh my goodness
how stressful it goes a lot faster than
you expect thank god for the dings yeah
thank god for the dings
should we walk around look at each
other's pictures yeah all right here you
go
whoa that looks great oh my god
and if you guys care to notice i added a
little
bob ross dude okay that looks really
cool but where's the crashing wave the
crashing wave is as far back as i could
humanly move it because it looks like
garbage because your lighting looks
really nice nice and suddenly your
lighting is good i like how soft and
subtle your sky is you know it really
feels painterly thank you guys i don't
see any sunlight shining through the
wave though i feel like it's a key part
of it i got it on the wave it does
actually look really good i'm thankful
i'm impressed i appreciate it
it looks like you accomplished what you
set out to do thank you guys
yeah sure okay let's let's look at what
i got here
oh that's not bad i am proud of you it
looks like a the bob ross fanning that
right through the wave is great that's
like spot on this needs like at least
another hour
i don't think so it really does not look
that different well like i wanted to add
like the shading on the tree the trees
are literally just like freaking 2d
cutouts right now the brushes you choose
the brushes are great like that looks
like a painting yeah and the sky is very
close your colors are spot on dude well
thank you i mean i'm i'm i'm pleased
with it this is the second thing i've
ever made where's your grass
oh no
[Laughter]
where's my grass here's mine
[Music]
what are these orbeez
what are those
wait are those
what is this
why is it green it's like you should
have jade why does it look like green
glass i thought you had a trick up your
sleeve with that wave plugging but it
looks like it backfired a little bit
this looks like waves out of like a like
a zelda game where they're kind of like
a little cartoony
but it's still very pleasing all right
sam show us what you got well
i got
this
it's a beach
rolling waves that looks pretty sweet
why is that also green are you guys
seeing the tv differently than i am i
don't see how you're seeing so much
green i forgot that they were supposed
to be blue at the last second and so i
haven't changed them yet is that being
said sam that that looks really cool
that actually does look like like waves
and water don't you feel like you could
just jump right into this painting and
walk around
yeah click the button
so obviously you start out as the main
character in this game and you come
stranded to this beach where you realize
that
so welcome to the uh port of saint
germain here in what way it's a very
rich story i mean there's a trade
economy you know they obviously sell a
lot of sugar and crabs if you go to the
marketplace you'll find lady cassandra a
fantastic backstory with this character
you know she's fallen in love with
the pirate deathbeard uh mccafferty this
is mccafferty's ship he's just boarded
the island yeah i'm shocked because you
you built like nine times more behind
the camera
the mayor's office is way over on that
side so yeah lord hamilton lives here
come on you can get through it
maybe try the basement entrance down
there you know there's some bugs we'll
work them out
how soon in the process were you done
with the beach portion i kind of did
that at the end when he started putting
the trees in i put the trees in and did
that and then the rest of the time was
spent doing everything else last time
was fun
what a quaint little island anyways uh
good times
all right leave a comment down below
with whose picture you like the best and
maybe a little reason why and we're
going to tally it all up and in a day or
two we'll post on our instagram who was
the winner of this bob ross challenge
also if you have any other cool vfx
challenge ideas please leave a
suggestion we love reading them they
help inspire us to make videos like this
one see you later